is the newest member of our eight news
now team you'll see him every day here
at 4pm with ted and i
let's take a little bit of time to
introduce christian you're from southern
california and ted and i understand you
are a big dog lover
that's right i have two dogs at home i
have a
five almost a five-month-old golden
doodle her name is lucy
and i have a two-year-old king charles
his name is mateo
and basically both of them are keeping
my partner and i very busy at home
so i mean we have the potty training
down but we're still kind of working
on the energy because as you guys all
know golden doodles are
very very uh energetic so yeah any
recommendations i'm all ears
well just give them lots of hug mine
likes to greet me by jumping up on me
and giving me a human hug so
just keep that going in the dog parks
ted's always tweeting out stuff about
all the cool parks around town we know
that
you also had some glorious hiking this
weekend
that's right my partner is very
outdoorsy so he finally convinced me to
go
out hiking for the very first time and
let me tell you it was nice it's nice to
go out there
taking a break you know just the
scenery's just taking
some fresh air disconnect turn off the
phone and just kind of be one with
nature
it was amazing and definitely we're
gonna definitely go out again good deal
he's loving it here yeah he is of course
and you know what's kind of trippy you
know how they say six degrees of
separation that kevin bacon film
well when you're in the media it's more
like two degrees ted and i worked
together in 1996
and the two of you worked together one
year too yes
yeah we were together in the east coast
in philadelphia
right and we had to deal with all that
snow not anymore
nope not anymore buddy very happy to be
here in las vegas
away from the snow yes we're happy to
have you here it's nice to go visit but
not to be
dealing with everything you don't have
to shovel no scraping windows
we're so happy to have you here
christian very happy to be here
and we did some fun wacky things with
him kind of behind the scenes so you can
check that out on our website
and christian's also taking over our
instagram for the evening so
find out more about him on that as well